welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 part one yes the
walking dead is back and the best way to
watch it is on amc plus link in the
description to sign up now and join in
for this epic final season of the
walking dead season 10 ended on a
cliffhanger when eugene and his crew
were ambushed by these stormtrooper
looking guys now we learn they're from
the commonwealth and our crew goes
through a long interrogation process
that's overly concerned about their
lives before the zombie apocalypse and
they really want to know the location of
their settlement but our crew's keeping
quiet not giving up alexandria
eventually yumiko is sick of waiting she
asks to speak to a manager yeah she was
a high-powered lawyer before who went to
harvard and oxford so now they're all
cleared congrats and welcome to the
commonwealth meanwhile back at
alexandria it's in pretty bad shape
remember the whisperers trashed it last
season and the most urgent problem
they're running out of food which is
becoming more and more difficult to
scavenge but now maggie is back on the
show and she's like hey the settlement i
just came from had a ton of food
unfortunately it was taken over by the
reapers they're a scary group that came
out of nowhere like ghosts but maggie's
like hey i ain't afraid of no ghosts so
we'll all roll up together and take them
out so the group sets off on a mission
and coming with them is big bad negan
he's been on a redemption arc the last
few seasons but maggie hasn't seen that
and is still real mad at him for killing
her husband glenn tensions are high
because at any moment she might decide
to just kill him and be done with it
when some walkers show up maggie and
negan are the last two climbing up this
train and maggie needs a help in hand
this could be a great opportunity for
negan to earn her trust by saving her
but he decides to go the other way with
it oh leaves her to fall mufasa at her
but maggie's not dying that easy she
manages to rejoin the group and negan's
like hey no hard feelings you would have
done the same thing to me and there's no
time to argue cause more walker's coming
for him maggie's got no choice but to
work with him to survive but it's daryl
who's the mvp here rolling up on the
zombies john wick style taking them all
out but the danger's not over cause now
they're ambushed by the reapers all
scary dudes wearing all black and creepy
masks it's a crazy fight these reapers
come out of nowhere and i hope you
didn't get attached to any of maggie's
new friends cause basically they all die
our group is all separated naturally
negan and maggie end up together with
just alden as a third wheel buffer but
alden's badly injured he can't keep
going so they leave him in this church
for now like maybe we'll see you later
so maggie and negan continue to work
together to survive though she still
might kill him at any moment and they
disagree on everything their arguments
get pretty heated but luckily father
gabriel shows up to mediate along with
maggie's one surviving friend elijah who
is the cool guy in the mask with the
ninja skills but he's not a mandalorian
who has to keep his mask on he takes it
off instantly like oh i'm a normal dude
meanwhile daryl is separated looking for
his best friend dog who has been picked
up by a reaper oh you don't want to mess
with john wick's dog but turns out daryl
knows this reaper because it's leah yeah
remember from the season 10 bonus
episodes she was daryl's girlfriend and
dog's original owner she takes him back
to the reaper compound turns out the
reapers were her original crew they were
all soldiers together and then
mercenaries before the apocalypse
daryl's like hey babe that's cool i
didn't even know those guys so i'll join
you so they give him the reaper entrance
exam which is stick him in a burning
shack and see if he survives and daryl
passes so he gets to meet the leader of
the reaper's pope as you might expect he
is a psychomegalomaniac who believes the
reapers were chosen by god why is it so
hard to meet normal people in the zombie
apocalypse the reaper's whole code is
loyalty to our brothers but pope kills
this brother for failing to save another
brother so now they're down two brothers
meanwhile back at alexandria the rest of
our characters are trying to hold things
together aaron has stepped up as the de
facto leader now carol's here too though
she doesn't do much little judith grimes
hangs out with the other kids the main
ones are her younger brother rick jr rj
aaron's daughter gracie and now maggie
and glenn's son herschel who's a cute
little kid then there's a really
memorable episode featuring connie who
made it out of the mines last season and
met up with virgil the guy michonne met
the walking dead goes full horror for an
episode when they take shelter in this
haunted house and oh are chased by these
creepy crawling zombies but wait those
aren't zombies these are living people
that have just gone full feral and
turned into gollum from lord of the
rings they managed to escape and just
then connie's sister kelly shows up
she's been searching for her and now
sisters reunited now back to the
commonwealth it is a massive successful
survivors community that seems to be a
nice happy place but the leader here is
governor pamela milton and we don't have
a great track record with governors now
remember the reason eugene came here is
for a booty call with stephanie his
radio girlfriend who turns out is real
she wasn't catfishing him but the
arguably more important reason they came
here is to get help for alexandria
stephanie agrees to help sneak him into
the radio tower so they can contact back
home but they gotta watch out for the
orange power ranger chief of security
mercer it's princess who takes point
distracting him basically by hitting on
him but that doesn't distract him for
long they're caught and in big trouble
their lawyer is lance hornsby who is
basically exactly better call saul and
he gets him off with just community
service clearing out walker duty king
ezekiel is here too by the way and if
you remember he's got cancer when they
find out the commonwealth hooks him up
with some first-class medical treatment
meanwhile yumiko's getting the vip
treatment she's being groomed for
leadership they're really impressed
she's a harvard grad and turns out
yumiko's long-lost brother is here yeah
siblings reunited but she's like hey bro
you were a successful surgeon what are
you doing working in a bakery but he's
like hey please don't tell anyone i was
a doctor i like the simple life of just
baking cakes unfortunately seems like
they found out and he's taken away so
yumiko goes for a meeting with pamela
milton by the way there might be
something going on with pamela milton's
assistant she's shown up a few times and
seems unusually interested in our group
so watch out for that for now stephanie
and eugene's sentence is almost up they
just have to clear one more section
where this rich preppy looking kid is
going on a picnic with his girlfriend
and indeed some walkers got in so eugene
and stephanie save their lives but they
don't get a thank you instead this kid's
like meh you ruined my picnic and he
goes too far when he insults stephanie
eugene clocks this kid in the face but
this is a much bigger deal than eugene
realized this kid is pamela milton's son
and it seems like the commonwealth has a
very strict class system now back to
maggie's mission which is down to just
four people negan's like hey i have an
idea but if i help i want your solemn
vow that you won't kill me negan's idea
is to get reinforcements from the
walkers oh whisperer style remember
negan was undercover with the whispers
for a while so he teaches maggie the
secrets of walking with the dead and now
finally these two try to squash their
beef negan's like yo i know i was the
bad guy from your perspective but you
guys were also the bad guy for mine now
it's been like six years and i hope you
can accept i'm part of this group but
it's one step forward two steps back
because negan doesn't apologize and
stands by killing glenn as the right
move at the time so maggie's still mad
but for now they're still working
together leaving their zombie horde
maggie and negan the new alpha and beta
they assault the reaper compound it's an
epic finale during his time undercover
daryl seen that leia's still a good
person and plants the seeds hey maybe
the reapers are the bad guys so now it's
time to reveal himself hey sorry girl
but i'm with them the reapers suck you
should join us lee is conflicted what's
she going to do but just then pope
unveils the reaper's secret weapon oh
it's a medieval rocket-propelled arrow
launcher but leah's like whoa if you
fire this thing you'll hit our brothers
who are down in the mix fighting and
pope's like hey if that's god's will
then that's what it is so now it's time
for the daryl pope showdown but it's
actually leo who gets him in the back
daryl's like awesome glad you joined the
light side but leah's not joining him
she's like pope had to go but the
reapers are still my brothers i'm
sticking with him oh she pulls a kylo
ren killed snoke but stayin on the dark
side and so as this first part of the
season comes to an end eugene's in big
trouble at the commonwealth finally
reveals alexandria's location at
alexandria they can't catch a break a
huge storm rolls through rosita goes out
and single-handedly takes down a horde
of zombies big hero moment but they
still get in and judith grimes and
gracie are trapped in the flooding
basement and at the reaper compound the
reapers fall back wait did we win no you
did not kylo leah's just pulled him back
so she can fire the huacha and oh that's
where part one of the season comes to an
end on a cliffhanger part two of this
final season of the walking dead starts
february 20th but you can watch the
premiere a week early february 13th only
on amc plus stream each new episode ad
free on demand plus get early access to
every episode the week before and be a
true walking dead insider the final
season is off to an epic start you gotta
find out what's going on with daryl
maggie and of course negan what's gonna
happen with leah and the reapers and
what's going on with the commonwealth
click the link in the description and
start your seven day free trial of amc
plus now's the time to join in and watch
part two of this epic three-part final
season of the walking dead
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member